scientists are predicting something
pretty awful a massive mega droughts
coming to the United States probably
around 20 50 so first we've got a quote
from the author of the study on this
natural droughts like the 1930s Dust
Bowl and the current drought in the
southwest have historically lasted maybe
a decade or a little less what these
results are saying is we're going to get
a drought similar to those events but
it's probably going to last at least 30
to 35 years now we've got a time lapse
of what they saying that this drought is
going to look like it's pretty well and
as you watch brown is bad but Brown is
bad here we go scientists looked at two
different possibilities first a
business-as-usual scenario where
worldwide greenhouse gas emissions
continue on their current course in this
case the future risk of lengthy droughts
rises to eighty percent alternatively if
the world were to take aggressive
actions to reduce emissions the model
still show drying but the trends will be
less severe okay so just to clarify what
you saw there the first time lapse was
what they're predicting and then the
second time lapse is what they're saying
if we actually make a change now no
we're not huge on science in this
country as you guys know if you watched
last week Ted Cruz is in charge of NASA
now which is a scary proposition it
doesn't believe in global warming by
NASA by charge of NASA but NASA in the
National Association of scamming America
am i right uh-uh when you see that [ __ ]
that kind of stuff now I know world
science people we believe in climate
change and all that I'm not a scientist
but a scientist give me information and
then I accept it um that's scary stuff
would you see that right yes um can't
why can't they come up with a thing that
cool if we can warm the planet why can't
we come up with something that cools the
planet you know my kevie every time it
snows rush limbaugh says see not me
there's got to be a way to make them
were the climate more frigid i mean can
it date some my old girlfriends man am i
right he did a rimshot there and no but
they actually do have the thing where
they would fly out of planes they do
like a chemtrail thing yeah and they
would there's a thing that they can
launch into the atmosphere that would
actually cool they don't know what the
effects you know there's all side
effects they don't know so
Beck's I do know how to cool yeah um I
mean look you can walk into any office
building in Phoenix in August and it's
totally pleasant like me we have we have
figured this out in runway right um did
you guys see interstellar by any chance
know did you see interstellar yeah I saw
it so inter so I mean this is basically
what the premise was that we become this
giant dust bowl then we can produce food
anymore then we have to go to other
planets to figure out how we can
continue uh that was that the time crews
will be back in makati yeah yeah one
jessica chastain right we see that there
do that thing too uh where is it going
to be raining it's gonna be raining
somewhere right is it I got when it with
the earthy heats up that means there's
more energy in the atmosphere which
means it's gonna be more weather events
so I'm be i'm confused how did why is it
gonna be droughty here be drought here
we're talking about the United States
but is NASA right there there are it's
our agency it'll rain somewhere or rain
somewhere out on but it's shitty for dis
rain just off the coast I think about
right might be yeah yeah but what's
clear about that what's interesting
about that and the important part is the
first of all by twenty that thing ended
in 2095 so in some ways you know gives
us yeah right right um but if your
children your children all right I have
a daughter I got um no uh is the we can
do something about I mean we can they
see you know it's not just us that was a
point of if all sort of the you know if
all the industrialized countries made
sort of thoughtful principled smart
staffs to [ __ ] climate change to
[ __ ] the warming and and fight climate
change then you get the second scenario
which is okay yeah like which is okay
yeah it's not it's not ideal but but
it's survivable so when I was reading
this I kept thinking about one of my
favorite George Carlin bits where he
says you know people this is from years
ago before everyone was talking about
climate change the way we talk about it
now this is like 15 years ago him
talking about how Earth's been through
cooling and we having and all and
meteors have hit and all this stuff and
you know what the earth is always going
to be here and it's egotistical of us to
think that it's all about us but I guess
we're we're self-interested are we I
mean we want to survive the planet will
always be here doesn't matter what we
put in the oceans whatever we're the
ones we're screwing so we're screwing up
the app
fear that has developed that would
sustain our life right but so we're
gonna screw up that atmosphere but earth
is gonna be here for so is that the flow
of the climate change people that
they're not focusing enough on make
they'd keep it the earth is changing
this is but we need to go this is about
us yet it would get people more excited
I don't think so because the reason why
people aren't accepting the science of
climate change is because they're being
manipulated by propaganda funded by oil
giants right so that's what this is
about yeah so is the only thing last
night is the only thing that's gonna
ever change the way we discuss this
stuff is that when we actually have a
food scarcity like when eventually it
gets so hot that our corn is gonna be
about corn our corn won't grow and then
that pretty much that to me seems like
the wake-up call when Americans can't
get food the way they get it now that
might be the thing I sort of see it as
the way it'll get fought is when the
people like the Koch brothers who were
just pure evil and funding evil and
there when you talk about this that's
their their their guys like them or what
and Men them and those guys themselves
or what's funding this propaganda
campaign when they recognize a way to
make money out of doing the right thing
and when there's a way for them to make
money when they see sort of green
strategies as a as a way to get rich uh
then then maybe we'll do something you
know by or something hideous happens to
people they care about because with so
many conservatives it only only affects
you well it's only real if it affects
only when their kid is gay oh then maybe
make maybe Gators okay yes
you